jaws good morning how are you dad I'm
doing terrific once again a pleasure
being with you and I was there 10 years
ago and I remember standing just outside
the tunnel as New Orleans Saints team
came on the field at that time I was
doing countdown we spent a few days down
in New Orleans and certainly had a
strong effect on even how I live my life
today when I saw the devastation that
city went through but when the saints
came on that field their feet were 10
feet in the air I mean that team was
flying I'm absolutely flying it was a
loudest crowd I had ever heard and they
certainly got that team to play the way
they did after Gleason's blocked punt
Atlanta had no chance that you're right
and I just thought how do they wrap
their head around this to play a
football game given the devastation
around the entire city and people were
dying people had died and then you go in
there and all of a sudden gleason blocks
the punt and then I realized that
Atlanta had no chance in there and it
was one of those remarkable moments
where you're able to see something good
come out of something so horrible only a
couple of hundred yards away yeah I
think it shows what what sport can
really do you know can bring people
together and certainly the new orlean
saints and their commitment to New
Orleans brought that city together for
one cause the saints we all know they
love their football team and and that
game with that team galvanized the city
at that moment let me go with
yesterday's games here so by the way its
Falcon Saints coming up tonight on the
mothership oddest result yesterday was
where oh there there were three odd
results in my opinion number one the
Steelers just getting crushed by the
Philadelphia Eagles right i mean i know
the Eagles are getting better the
Steelers are good that that game was
just it was a devastating game for the
Pittsburgh Steelers as far as just
watching the way they were handled by
the Philadelphia Eagles I thought
Minnesota being able to go down to
Carolina and win that football game and
just harassed
all day all day long on him and then the
Denver Broncos shouldn't be much of a
surprise but going into Cincinnati and
winning that game somewhat handily III
think since daddy's a tremendous team
you know they started out you know 911
in New York and they got to go to
Pittsburgh I thought they finally had a
home game and they would show what the
Bengals are about so for Denver to go in
there win that game was surprising to me
as well so there were 33 shocker games
to me yesterday let me start with Carson
Wentz you played in that city the
expectation levels are high but he goes
in there he wouldn't be starting if they
didn't get the opportunity to unload Sam
Bradford was it always there or is it
just learning on the job jaws it was
always there I had Carson Wentz's my
number one quarterback coming out on my
quarterback draft board and after I
studied Carson and all his games in
North Dakota State actually went out for
his pro day and spent three days out in
lovely Fargo in the grades North Dakota
State University fans and not only you
know talk to Carson but his teammates as
coaches fans sponsors you name it that I
worked the city trying to get that some
dirt on Carson Wentz there is none this
is a special young man now outside of
the football talent which you've now
seen through three games you know he's
grounded he's faith-based he's family
he's smart you know his Wonderlic score
was 4015 highest ever recorded his grade
point average is four point oh he's
humble and he's playing in a tough city
of Philadelphia and he's handled it all
very well dan it's it's almost shocking
when you consider he's only played one
preseason game memory broke his rib he
didn't play for the next three games he
missed practice eight days before the
opener Sam Bradford is traded to
Minnesota Carson Wentz gets a starting
job and he's played like Peyton Manning
didn't his tenth year it's remarkable
tougher to succeed in Philadelphia at
that position or in dallas which is what
dak Prescott's doing right now that way
by the way dak Prescott is playing
phenomenal football as well i I'm just
so blown away to see these two young
quarterbacks as rookies to start opening
day and play as well as they are that's
supposed to be
they're making it look easy but you
don't feel a delta because of the nature
and the blue-collar nature of the city
the demands are excessive the passion is
through the roof I think it makes it a
little bit harder to succeed in
Philadelphia but certainly Carson
Wentz's has warned the city of
Philadelphia over and in three weeks
he's Ron Jaworski from the mothership
tonight falcons saints Monday Night
Football are the Broncos in better shape
at the quarterbacking position this year
than last year you know it's funny I
just stepped in my office NFL films
about half hour ago and I started
looking at that Denver tape and got some
Trevor Simeon tape and and this guy's
the real deal I I thought tell me in
this season you know there was very
little fanfare about Trevor Simeon it
was taxing Lynch was going to be the
quarterback it was Mark Sanchez it was
going to keep the seat warm for Paxton
Lynch Trevor Simeon has been phenomenal
yesterday his ability to process
information to make decisions wasn't
incredible he throws the ball with
velocity his ball placement is very good
yes excellent accuracy it's going to be
hard to get this guy off the field right
now the Denver Broncos are a very good
football team that's a really good
Cincinnati Bengal team they handled I
don't know if you know what this feeling
is like but Ryan Fitzpatrick throwing
six interceptions what's the most you
ever had and again thanks Dan it's not
six like just know it's hard to throw
six ever scored in hey I burn that paper
to go but but but it's kind of funny on
the off season you know i do my
quarterback big board and i go through
all the throws of all the quarterbacks
in the offseason when I could just sit
here and just just rip through the
throws and when I went through Ryan
Fitzpatrick you know you look at the
numbers what 31 touchdowns 15 pics it
last season he should have had 30
interceptions he had at least 15 dropped
interception and that's always kind of
stayed in my mind that personally I
can't trust Ryan Fitzpatrick you know it
is a guy that you'll love that
aggressive attitude you love that
gunslinger mentality but you know to win
consistent in a National Football League
you've got to be judicious with the
Paul and Fitzpatrick has always been
careless with the football yes he makes
plays he can extend plays he moves out
the pocket he makes some great throws
they have a terrific receiving corps but
if you're throwing interceptions you're
not winning what happens when Brady
returns to the Patriot they'll keep
winning I mean what's happened in New
England is just remarkable and you know
I we should not be surprised Bill
Belichick and what he does josh
mcdaniels just you know the the
chameleon game plan every single week
something different no matter who the
quarterback is you know when you can go
with Jimmy Garoppolo week one and find a
way to win out in Arizona against a very
good Arizona team when you can bring out
a rookie quarterback a week three and
win a football game your third quarter
back and win a football game it just
shows you the the type of ability that
Bill Belichick Josh Daniel have in
coaching a Jacoby Brissett a Jimmy
Garoppolo at Gronkowski's out Ninkovich
is out if they understand the team
concept of football before I let you go
what was your superbowl pick and would
you like to change it you know I don't
remember that's a convenient answer
their jaws so obviously didn't like what
would you kick right now well I I think
no women right now in Minnesota or the
tombs of two teams i really like
basically you know small sampling and
I'm always very careful I always like to
let four weeks play out just you know
scheduling teams you know that are going
through that rebuilding process or
building process you really don't know
until a quarter of the seasons played
but I'll get myself another week before
I really zero in on it but i think the
wing playing a great level and so's
minnesota on defense to just could just
take people out of games just good to
have you on we appreciate it thanks for
joining us and always great to be with
you thank you thanks buddy the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience